si boris johnson avait dans un premier
temps soutenu la stratégie de l'immunité
collective à savoir laisser le virus se
propage et pour qu'une majorité soit
contaminée et développent des anticorps
coronavirus il a finalement décidé le 23
mars dernier l'imposer un confinement au
royaume uni peu de temps avant d'être
lui même contrôlé positif après un peu
plus d'un mois et alors que se dessine
une baisse lente mais continue des
victimes ducobu 19
les autorités britanniques envisagent à
présent un déconfinement progressif
l'objectif de test track and chest et de
traquer et d'isoler le virus afin qu'ils
sont incapables de se reproduire et
surtout l'application nous permet
d'adopter une approche plus ciblée du
confinement tout en contenant en toute
sécurité la maladie la création de ce
système est une vaste entreprise
nationale d'une ampleur et d'une
complexité sans précédent l'application
va tester sur la plus grande ville
d'angleterre celle de wight au sud dû
payer pour être généralisé à partir du
mois de juin
si le royaume uni a vraisemblablement
passé le pic de l'épidémie
la sortie du confinement soulève de
nombreuses questions notamment sur le
retour à la vie active de milliers de
britanniques ragoubi sept miracles et
nex oui je présenterai un plan complet
la semaine prochaine pour expliquer
premièrement comment nous pouvons faire
bouger notre économie
deuxièmement comment nous pouvons
envoyer nos enfants à l'école ou dans
les crèches
et troisièmement comment nous pouvons
nous rendre au travail et comment nous
pouvons rendre la vie au travail plus
sur sypher depuis le début du
confinement 20% des actifs soit 6
millions de personnes sont au chômage
partiel et ont recours aux aides de
l'état
si ce rythme est jugé insoutenable par
le ministre britannique des finances
les indemnisations d'urgence du
gouvernement ne sont pas appelées à
cesser et ce en dépit de l'effondrement
économique auxquels le pays fait face